hey guys welcome to the evident caitlyn
podcast the podcast that was until
recently literally covered in insulation
[Music]
alright guys welcome to another evident
killin podcast me good i just fell
through the ceiling i mean not not i
didn't just fall through the ceiling
that was a few days ago story time
podcast yeah um we just have a lot of
thoughts around that incident and we
wanted to share the story share the
thoughts because i think it led to some
interesting conversations do you what
happened okay yeah so we were in the
attic working on a ceiling i mean
working on flooring we were installing
flooring in our attic so that we could
store more stuff variable project that
just came out um a couple days ago if
you're listening to this monday and so i
was just talking about how the floor up
there isn't that sturdy and how we need
to replace it with a more sturdy floor I
walk over and I fall through well it's
not just that what's that we did that
take three times oh yeah the first time
wasn't great so so we're up there and
it's you know like a talking scene but
there's a few specific points we're
trying to hit but we're also trying to
be concise but also fast and sometimes
it's kind of hard to do especially when
it's like midnight and you're you've
been sweating in an attic and you just
wanna be done so we did the line once it
was like okay we did it again it was
pretty good the second time was pretty
good and we liked that the crazy thing
is like we were going back and forth
like should we do it again should we not
do it again cuz like I get worse and
worse the more takes I do I'm not that
good at saying the same things bold old
times the first is usually the best
because it's the most genuine but I was
feeling like pretty good you know I was
like you know what my attitudes pretty
good I'm feeling this I can do it one
more time let's do it one more time and
I feel like I can do it better and more
concise so we did it one more time one
more time and that's that's the the
thing that's included
in the video but we'll get into that
later and I walk over I slip I fall
through the roof I fall through the
ceiling and oh man that was just a
horrible moment what went through your
head like did you have did it happen in
slow motion when you fell it looked like
slow motion to me when you felt cuz this
whole time because we were filming it
take like I had the camera in my hands
and I was filming yeah and I was still
in like filming mode too in like YouTube
mode and like the the sad thing or the
interesting thing let's just say
interesting the interesting thing that
went through my head as I felt this
feeling this like who I call myself
let's look back at the camera just in
case it's interesting like oh geez are
my priorities straight probably not but
you know oh gosh it's just so far in my
head you know and I guess I am I was in
filming mode but like I mean immediately
afterwards I was like oh my gosh that
could have been so much worse that was
like the small part of what was running
through my head but I mean I mentioned
it in the video like I pulled myself
back up III got up nice and carefully
and slowly made sure that I was safe
fooling myself back up and then I looked
down at the mess that our office was and
I'm just like ah I just do not want to
deal with this at this point we had been
sweating in the Attic for like hours by
that point it was 11 something at night
or midnight even later or midnight we
were so tired and done and this is gonna
be the last thing that we were gonna do
that night we were gonna finish that
take and we were gonna go to bed shower
and go to bed it was going to be nice
like perfect conclusion to the day and
it literally went downhill oh and it's
this is like the worst room for
insulation to fall on because it's all
of our electronics so it felt like all
over our editing computer all over our
soundboard and our streaming / podcast
computer yeah there is insulation all in
these microphones like this computer is
still
scarred up on the edges where there's
like drywall grit embedded on the
computer we're still cleaning up dust
yes
days later I lost a single key on my
keyboard which like I don't know how it
hit yeah you're right control key just
like shattered yeah I don't know I tried
to install it afterwards but like the
little hooks on it were broken off so I
literally can't reinstall that key just
that one key though like it's so weird
it was like nope oh man but like you
know I'm pretty proud about how we dealt
with that we both like kind of took we
only took five minutes I'm just like
sitting up in the attic looking through
the hole just looking I don't think we
said much did we no we just kind of sat
there look down the hole looked at each
other said some slightly profane words I
think yeah they were profane words
Leonard we usually don't cuss in the
video I had to bleep it out oh yeah when
you fell yeah I think I said some more
more strongly-worded through the hole at
everything covered in insulation like
the funny thing is is like the
insulation was just like going around
our computers getting sucked up in the
vents but we just kind of couldn't move
we were just kind of like sitting there
staring down and we just like took a few
minutes yeah you know I most the time
I'm really happy that we have blown
insulation it was so easy to DIY
ourselves it's nice because it's like a
green recycle fiber so you know with all
the work up there we don't get very
itchy like it all really like it's not
as bad if you happen to breathe some in
like there's so many benefits but in
that moment I was like god dang I wish
we just had insulation batting and
that's it bad yeah I'm looking at the
other art piece that we did like the
twisted wood veneer art to my left and
they're still like fiber pieces just
suck all up in there
yeah yeah yeah I'm
we're gonna be fine pretty sure like
years later we're gonna be finding bits
of it around our office yeah I found
some like embedded in the t-slot
aluminum mask but I mean like that's
another crazy thing what's that it's
like oh yeah the scary part yeah the
scary part is like just under where the
hole is so our main desk not the
streaming desk we're on right now the
rainbow resin LED when the older one
that we made it is also made of aluminum
extrusions and because it used to be a
standing desk the four posts like the
legs are high at standing height in case
we ever want to raise it back up but
right now there it's lower to a normal
height so we just have like these four
posts sticking up these four aluminium
posts and one of them is right under
where the hole is yeah it's pretty sharp
it's like sharp edges with a metal post
yeah I'm really looking at that like
great kind of that would be bad to fall
on that do you really like anything in
here would be bad to fall on anything
there's not like a beanie cushion
because that's the thing yeah that might
be a thing I don't know but uh yeah that
was that was a scary part like thinking
about like what could have been and we
just didn't let ourselves go down that
path too much we couldn't we had to like
immediately clean up because we couldn't
let it most people would have just like
called it a day
closed the door shut everything down
it's like left it to deal with tomorrow
but no we like swept up we cleaned up we
vacuumed the ceiling carpet off the
ceiling so that you know we weren't
losing a see we like fully cleaned up
that night yeah until like 12:40 then we
had gone oh no then oh yeah III died I
had the i/o crass I'm like I want french
fries and ice cream right now because
that seems like something good to do
decompress so we into McDonald's cuz
it's like the only place open and we got
well and fries are delicious yeah we got
french fries and some ice cream and we
just ate that we just like sat down at
our living room dining room table yeah
and a shared ice cream and french fries
because we're adults and we can do that
that's how we like to deal with our
emotions healthy walk which is a little
bit healthier way to do their emotions
they're still kind of like wound up so
we're going yeah we did go for a long
walk it was like 1:30 in the morning at
that point luckily we live in a safe
area yeah a lot of late walks oh yeah I
was so crazy because like we were
walking around and it was complete
silence there are no cars no people it
was just like just two of us yeah yeah
yeah oh man yeah so that's that's kind
of what happened and like looking
through the footage I mean I kind of see
how it happened I was probably rushing a
little bit I wasn't taking the time
placing my feet where they should have
been what's hard cuz in your head you
were trying to keep track of like I got
to say this and I gotta do this scene
quickly yeah because that was the main
thing is that we were struggling to get
all the information in a concise scene
mm-hmm yeah and usually I have like two
or three points of contact I like to
have like one solid foot and then my
hand somewhere and then the other foot
is searching but I have like two feet on
the same beam and my hand was on like
another place but it just wasn't enough
like I mean the good news is you you
kept your hand on that beam yeah you
know it just slipped down the beam yeah
you like kept a hold on it because I was
reviewing this limbo footage and and
like your foot that did have a solid you
know spot it stayed up so it was just
your right leg that went down through
the ceiling yeah one leg say that both
arms stayed up above and I caught myself
with multiple points yeah so I like
spread out the bruising so it's like
spread out between somehow both my legs
got bruised and both my arms got bruised
but like all very light bruising yeah
and my back yeah I'm surprised though
I'm surprised it's not worse I was able
to like walk around and function that
night yeah you bruiser showed up more a
few days later but um that night did we
review the footage that night no we
didn't do it to the next day I think I
think didn't we review it on the camera
oh did we I think we did or is like
Clinton's
I just wanted to like see it for some
reason I don't know why I just wanted to
like see how bad it was
ya can confirm was bad was that
but it's so painful watching it cuz like
for us like we knew it was gonna happen
to our watching watching and like we
start cringing in advance over the fall
and yeah yeah but I think we watched it
on the camera that night do we and we
started discussing that that night for
some reason yeah well you know again
yeah that was that was hard to answer
because you know we always try to
include the mistakes that we make in our
video so like if we're doing a res
important we mess up we include it if
we're building a catio and we cut what
you know the legs wrong we include it
because I feel like it makes projects
more approachable if you're someone
watching you know if you see that you
know these people you're watching mess
up and then you mess up it's like well
it's okay that I mess well it also looks
like we do like almost a version one for
everybody so that you can do version two
you know it's like we do it making it
yeah I know thank you making it guys
yeah it's like it's like you know the
people who make youtube videos we show
us doing it for the first time and
hopefully you guys can learn from it and
you know make the version two right away
after the mistakes that we made so so
yeah it's definitely our instinct to
always include the mistakes but at the
same time this was a serious thing could
have been really bad could have been
really bad when we called cuz because we
um
we didn't have time to fix this
ourselves no because there's a you know
specific deadline with the project and
even though we knew we probably could
push we just didn't want to push it
because it would have pushed everything
and so we were calling around to hire it
out and we were talking to two people
about the ceiling repair the first
version we talked to was like oh yeah I
have had to fix ceilings or people died
and it was like oh my gosh like so it's
it's you know and when you see in movies
it's like a comical thing that happens
yeah when I heard that I was like oh I
don't know if we can include this
because it's a serious thing and we
don't to make light of a serious thing
about the same time if we do want to
raise awareness that there is a danger
and then like you know we were talking
with other people and they're like but
guys you know people have died doing
almost everything so it's like are you
gonna prevent yourself from showing like
using a table using a table saw
in right that's kind of a good point you
know cuz but at the same time it's like
it's not like we had kicked back and
that's true you know I mean yeah it's
true so yeah but we went back and forth
a lot starting on the night that it
happened you know at McDonald's during
our walk and one thing that's
interesting is like telling my parents
about it is actually when I started
rethinking like that we might include it
because that night we concluded no we
can't show that that's it's like too
dangerous it's too serious and how could
we like be going about our normal videos
which we try to make like light-hearted
and fun because we do have fun and it is
a I don't know I think that the the
videos that we make the time that we
spend together is a very fun thing and
we like sharing that this like that
making and doing things is fun it leads
a nice sense of accomplishment and you
know it's like that's the type of video
we want to make you know and it was hard
to mix that vision of our videos with
this serious thing that happened you
know I just didn't see how we could do
it also you know during that first night
we had not yet found the like irony and
humor really yeah like we we hadn't
gotten to the point where we could look
back and laugh at it so that first night
we were like no this is terrible we are
not gonna include it yeah nobody nobody
wants to like see this terrible thing
well like when I was telling the story
to my parents that's when I started
finding the humor in it because I kind
of had to make it funny for them
otherwise like
I don't know I didn't want to depress
them or anything but like you know
finding the humor in it like saying like
right before I fell through the ceiling
I said like oh I almost fell through the
ceiling wouldn't that have been like
really crazy if I you know it's like all
of the ironic things about what actually
happened yeah the fact that we were
installing floors to make it safer yeah
literally right before you would stepped
on a creaky board that kind of popped
and you're like we knew have been crazy
if I fell through right now into our
office Wow the foreshadowing the
foreshadowing yeah so it's like we found
the humor in it at that point and then
we started coming back around to like oh
maybe we can include this in the video
yeah you know yeah we do we did call
like so this is a low sponsored video
and we called the agency we work with
like with Lowe's to ask their opinions
on like do you think we can include this
is it
you know is it weird cuz it's not
necessarily on brand for like a home
improvement channel to show this usually
it's like experts presenting how to do
things but I think that you know part of
our identity is again
showing people like what we've learned
in the mistakes and bringing you guys
along this adventure with us and you
know being true to you know the truth of
that adventure well yeah I don't know
you know what I mean yeah my words are
hard thanks thanks make fun of the guy
who just fell through the ceiling
minutes ago not really minutes ago days
ago days ago the recent traumatic
experience but yeah they were they're
pretty cool with the idea of us
including it you know we kind of pitched
how we wanted to include it like we
wanted to give some lessons learned but
also you know keep it kind of positive
and yeah and before we pick we before we
reached out to them we kind of had to
edit it cuz I was like I don't know if I
can edit this in and keep that balance
of like we want to communicate this is
this is a really serious and scary thing
that happened and we want
communicate how to avoid it but we also
want to keep it light-hearted and it was
it was kind of tough it was tough yeah
it was tough to strike that balance
tough to strike that balance how was it
editing it um not bad once I got going
not bad once it was harder to like like
the brainstorming beforehand about like
what we wanted to say water than edit
how was like editing that sequence of me
falling through the roof like seeing it
again and again in the game yeah because
I did like repeat it multiple times in
slow motion um I think by that point it
it had become footage oh you know the
first three times we watched it together
it was that's that's when it like the
clenching was happening you know by the
time I was editing it into the video we
had already watched it so many times
yeah I think it was just it was footage
yeah it was just like you could pretend
like it was just part of the project you
know you're right it was like any other
slow motion think because you know
there's often times where something will
happen and I cut back to a clip of it in
slow motion you know and it just kind of
became one of those yeah you know you
just watch it enough times that's weird
yeah that's weird yeah one thing that's
also kind of weird to me about this is
so this happened Thursday night sure I
think it happened Thursday night because
I remember the day after it was launch
day
oh you're right so we were we were
launching the video the next day and the
crazy thing to me is um be filled oh
yeah the zombie flail video and you know
we've had lots of setbacks before you
know with with the table that we're at
we like put the rods in at the wrong
place we have had curing issues with
silicone we've had all these different
issues and all sorts of other projects
and usually the delay due to those
issues is quite long yeah you know but
just partially because of the day it was
launching and everything and partially
just because we didn't have the time to
fix it like on Friday we called a
drywall or a pear person
and they came and they fixed it while we
were launching in the other room and the
whole delay of me falling through the
ceiling was about like an hour's worth
of our time cleaning up that's the
entire length of time it delayed us it
was actually like our smallest setback
what do you think timewise me falling
through the ceiling not the roof yeah
was the smallest delay we've had in a
project like other than that it was
really smoothly everything went as
planned it's pretty weird that reminds
me of another like ironic thing is when
we were looking at drywall repair our
own video on how to patch and repair
drywall popped up and we were like oh I
did briefly think because we when we
were trying to brainstorm about how to
include it and we were like well I don't
know if it should be in in this video is
it gonna like throw off the whole vibe
so I did briefly think like what if we
do it another video that's how to patch
your ceiling and it's part of that video
but we just really didn't want to do it
and we didn't have time yeah yeah this
wasn't time well but also I mean there's
a big difference between patching a
little hole or a small hole a medium
hole and a large hole versus patching a
giant hole in your ceiling yeah in a
room with your computers yeah because we
didn't move the computers and desks all
the way out we pushed them up against
the walls because these desks are really
big we built them in this room and they
are able to be disassembled because they
are T sawed aluminum and like watching
the professionals come in here like
people who do this all the time and fix
it up they like taped it up in this
really great way I should have like
brought you in here to show you at bug
they did the tape in a certain way so
that like they taped up the whole thing
with just the sticky side showing and
then once all the tape was in place and
there's sticky showing all the way
around then they stuck the drop cloth to
the tape so they did the tape and not
the drop cloth and like they
put the tape in a certain way so that it
was like sticking down and everything
and then they added the drop cloth to it
and it was like like wielding the drop
cloth while you're trying yeah that's
very interesting they did the whole
thing with tape and then they did a drop
cloth so there's all these little tips
and tricks that people who do this all
the time
know for these like big jobs for the
small drops it's like kind of the same
thing but for the big repairs for
drywall stuff yeah there's just like
things that people who do this all the
time know that we just don't know don't
notice because we haven't done it yeah
that many times you know and we never
done SC language no we did remember the
right over there the water damage it was
just before YouTube we did we patched
like a 2 foot by 2 foot hole in the
ceiling and it took us two days it did
and it still doesn't look great hey you
know what it was a learning experience
yeah so on that one in particular we we
took out a square of drywall okay we cut
between these two beams it's a square
yada-yada-yada
we had a leak that's like a horrible
leak oh that's why okay you know in the
attic video when we are giving like the
attic tour yeah and we showed that
quote-unquote breakfast nook and the
quote-unquote sink yep where the sink is
that's where we had to replace a pipe
because the old pipe was leaking so we
just like quickly went up and like
haphazardly sod through the plywood to
try to reach the pipe to replace it
quickly because it was leaking in the
hallway yeah yeah it was like we came
back from work one day and we noticed
that the ceiling was sagging so I
figured no I came back home I came back
and I saw water on the floor oh you said
water on the floor I thought we poked it
with a nail or something
Yesi well I put a bucket under there and
I waited for you to get home because
they don't want to poke it by myself in
case it's just there's like a rush of
water I think I poked it with the nails
I'm okay if it's already dry up there I
can poke it with a nail it'll let the
water out and then we can see what it
was I poked it with a nail and I was
like
yeah it was like rained down yeah and
the reason the patch job looks so bad is
cuz the drywall got all like saggy and
warped and we didn't want to pass it out
even more we did because then we would
have had to go around lights and yeah
yeah I don't like ceiling refuses slap
bass job yeah you know it took two days
it's cuz I kept layering on more and
more mud to try to like like bridge the
gap in the slope and the height
difference so much mud and that like
drywall mud in that section it's fine
more mud than drywall yes okay what are
we saying we also have to admit that one
one reason why we kind of wanted to
include the following footage in the
video is like falling through a ceiling
isn't a pleasant experience but one made
a mate one way to make it like more
worth it it's like get some benefit from
it and I know that that sounds so like
you to burry or something but on YouTube
retail you admit what you're thinking or
what you were thinking cuz like it might
lead to more clicks more views it might
like make the thumbnail better you know
if we can make we still haven't made the
thumbnail so hopefully we make something
good out of it but it's like you know we
never try for sensationalism content but
like if I'm gonna fall through a roof
ceiling I might as well get some views
out of it right I don't know is it weird
to think that it feels weird but I also
can't help but think it and we also like
reached out to another youtuber a friend
and he kind of like felt the same way he
was like he was like immediately he's
like do it definitely do it weird it
feels like capitalizing on a bad thing
that happened yeah it's sweet but it was
like real it wasn't manufactured no it
wasn't manufactured and I'm not doing it
for the views but like I can't confirm
you did not fall do it ceiling for you
no but I don't even know them we don't
know like the effect it'll have yeah it
might lead to like bad things who knows
like because we did we didn't think like
there's a risk reward there's like a
risk that
bad things could result from us and
keeping it in there or good thing this
is like a little bit of a roll the dice
a type gamble you know yeah and by the
way we usually we record the Monday
podcast after the Friday video is
released we're doing this one a little
bit earlier because we wanted to do it
well the fall is still fresh so the
video the attic video is not out yet
there's a chance those could call us
back and be like no actually don't
include it there's a chance it'll tank
there's a chance it'll go viral we have
no idea what's gonna happen
all speculation at this point I don't
think that this is gonna go viral I mean
like I don't think an attic organization
video is gonna go viral oh my god I
doubt it you know I'm just speaking in
extremes yeah yeah so by the time this
comes out you guys will be exciting yeah
but it but it was kind of strange
because we you know we didn't know if we
would get pushback we've done some
things that are like questionably safe
before but like that we always felt like
relatively comfortable doing especially
because we're not like showing ourselves
as experts but this one just did feel
more dangerous and we wanted to like we
we don't want it to come off that like
we didn't take it seriously you know you
know that anything I worry about I have
someone to admit what after we patched
the ceiling in and the hole in the
ceiling I actually had a thought like
dang it I should have gotten more photos
of me up there for the thumbnail it's
like I could have gone back up there
like stuck my leg through and you could
have gotten some photos like like that
that like frame it right and like show
the dramatic miss of it we could have
set up the tripod and you could have
like like shown like you your hands
pushing my foot back up through the
attic or something and it's like I kind
of regret that too but is it weird that
I regret that because that seems almost
more capitalizing on it and then it
makes it fake almost you know yeah yeah
well I have mixed thoughts and when we
when we were you know having people come
fix it at that point we were on
the not included side of the fence yeah
like we were thinking we weren't going
to yeah and it wasn't until it was
already fixed that we started flipping
back and forth yeah yeah I know I kind
of feel that way too
this is bust through again and get
another thumb hahaha
JK but yeah but I also feel but really
weird and bad for feeling that way I
know I don't know emotions emotions are
real it is like doing what what we do
like it does get in your head not like
this job is all-consuming coz like we
try not to judge are the like the the
value of our video based on the views
likes and shares but at the same time
you do you do I mean it's just being
realistic here I don't know yeah yeah
and maybe maybe more seasoned veteran
youtubers are past the point of caring
but like we still care a lot we've only
been doing this for a couple years and
it's like I feel like people who've done
it longer still care to I don't know how
seasoned do you gotta be to just be like
yeah whatever now what I also like to
say is well now that we're a little bit
bigger we don't need the growth as much
we don't need the views as much I don't
care as much but I don't think that
that's true at all well for me it's like
yes you know we managed to make this a
full-time job like we're not struggling
to pay bills or anything like that so in
that aspect yeah we're fine but what we
do struggle with is time and if we got
to a point where we didn't have to have
a sponsor in every video or we can make
like one last video a month yeah yeah
or like it wasn't as big of a deal you
know right now we just recently in the
past couple months started taking buffer
weeks every now and then and that's been
a huge huge help and that was because
financially we could have one less
sponsor a week but like growing and
being able to make more money per video
just means that we wouldn't have to work
so hard all time
um so that's why that's and there's oh
I'm not even sheriff sure if I've shared
this like Evan and Caitlin I are like
III have this like list running
somewhere in my Google Documents called
the Evan life cheat sheet and I think
that one of the things I've kind of like
realized at some point during one of our
walks is like it's not that if you love
what you do you'll never work a day in
your life it's if you love your work
you'll always be working and it's still
work but you want to do it yeah like
that's what we want to do but there
definitely is a big difference between
needing to work and wanting to work and
working I'm not sure if that makes sense
do those words make work something like
that so it's like okay let me see if I
can say this a little bit better if if
we didn't have to work what we would be
doing is pretty much this yeah that's
true you know but if we have to do this
because of sponsors and schedule and
stuff like that then it feels like we're
being forced to do it so they're very
similar but like that differential is
also huge in terms of like what it means
for us yeah yeah it's just like a mental
switch switch yeah yeah and not only in
terms of how much time we have to put
into things but also if like if we had
less sponsors we would have a little bit
more freedom in terms of what type of
projects we could do some sponsors are
really chill about it some sponsors have
more specific ideas but yeah also like
you know there would be a little bit
less worry about a videos performance I
guess yeah but I don't know I say that I
think it would always get to me well one
one thing that really does help I think
with like all the things we need to
manage and everything is not needing to
worry about our podcast website I've
been in Caitlin podcast.com you know
because Squarespace is up all the time
they monitor it they keep everything
good to go
you know they have beautiful themes over
on Squarespace I didn't have to design
that you know no updates no plugins when
you're when you're up in the attic and
you check your your podcast website use
blood your foot yep and then there it is
it's just working that's the one thing I
didn't have to worry about the whole
attic saga yeah you know at least that
wasn't a stress on top of everything
else so thank you Squarespace for
sponsoring this podcast yep if you want
to check out Squarespace and make an
awesome website you can do a free trial
at squarespace.com and if you want to
save 10% off your first purchase you can
go to Squarespace comm slash Evan and
Kaitlyn podcast that was good thank you
I thought of it and I was sitting here
getting excited basically but I didn't
know the words right I could because
there there wasn't any noise but I could
so like feel part of it but yeah but it
is it is strange how um like this job
does become such a big part of things
like of the way you think about
everything yeah like and we've seen it
in tiny bits before like and I think
it's been a good thing mm-hmm
like when project stuff goes wrong we've
mentioned this before I think I'm like
patreon after shows but when something
goes wrong you know we think like well
bad for the project good for the good
good for the video you know I also think
that my gosh like that the attic storage
is a perfect example of our job pushing
us and allowing us to do projects that
would want to do but might have a hard
time finding the time for if it weren't
for our channel you know being in your
attic is not fun and like we might have
done it during winter and it wouldn't
have been as yeah taxing to us yeah it's
like you know we're coming
projects in the winter why why why don't
we do past I don't know I think
hopefully we're done with attic projects
now hopefully but like the attic storage
it legit is so nice walking up there I
feel so much safer with like the proper
like boards put into place all the
things covered like it really is a huge
benefit to us and I don't know if I'd do
that if it weren't for like the job
pushing us yeah that is very true and I
think we can say that about a lot of
yeah I don't think they would have
learned welding or blacksmithing at if
it weren't for yeah like I think if I
wasn't pushed to do things I'd probably
just do like a lot of resin and more art
really
yeah or like occasionally stuff we
actually need yeah but it is nice it
also is very strange strange that
exchange that what well this is the
strange in general in terms of like how
we think about life and how we spend our
time and what projects we want to do and
and like what is worth our time and
everything that kind of like the whole
gaming thing it's like we kind of cut
games out of our lives until we could
figure out a way to make them mean
something for our business with you know
twitch and Eminem killing gaming healthy
or not healthy kind of thing maybe we
should title this this podcast like Evan
fell through the roof and it made us
rethink our life it's not really over
dramatis izing things cuz it didn't
really make us rethink our life but it
made us think about our life a little
bit yeah yeah good question like what
what's motivated by fuse and what's
motivated by your own thoughts I don't
know buddy the whole the whole shift in
our channel I mean we've made we've
changed one we've made podcast we've
changed too so there's two podcasts we
talked about like us changing in general
so if you want to like hear more about
the first like set of changes went
through in this the second set of
changes and I think we're still in the
progress of what we talked about and
that we've changed part
- what we're talking about like our
shift more towards like fun and
entertaining things that just make us
happy and that are like gonna be
exciting for us to do but I think that
that shift is like you know done for the
right reasons for us our internal
reasons not for external reasons you
know the mean so I think that we are
thinking about things from the right
perspective even though it's like we
still do want to view is about like you
know I mean we talked about in we've
changed part two but like in December
our views were dropping things weren't
doing well yet we still continue to push
that's true
so you know I feel like we are swayed by
the views and the performance but at the
same time we're dedicated to push
through it even if there is a cost
because the cost of giving in and just
doing what performs the best would be
worse in the long term because then
you're putting yourself more and more
and more into a box and then you realize
you're in this box and you can't escape
yeah and then that's the worst yeah and
we we very much think about the long
term a lot a lot a lot so we're always
like future proofing things yeah and one
of those things is our channel and the
type of content we want to make because
we don't want to get boxed in to too
much yeah I avoid it as much as possible
and that's why we're spending a lot of
money on Evan and Calum gaming and we're
not getting like any money back really
but like it's it's like we're spending
the money to hire editors to help us
create this content because we don't
have time and we know eventually this
investment in the channel is gonna be
work worth it we have the faith in large
part because of evident gatling our main
channel you know and we see where all
this is going but I think that you know
that's not their long-term thinking
right there yeah investing in ourselves
yeah well and and with the gaming stuff
you know like you're saying it earlier
that's something we used to do a lot of
and so making it like a long-term viable
part of the business will allow us to
keep doing the thing that we really like
doing and so yeah
long-term balance words Thanks well you
know it really makes me happy what my
thing of the week
and that is minecraft oh my gosh
minecraft is just in my head all the
time I know this is your thing a week
technically but I'm gonna agree with you
because I feel like I've I've spent a
lot of time since our most recent
minecraft stream like just thinking in
blocks you know I still want to make
like glass ruse and like rearrange our
house and make it brighter and better
and like we've only we've only played it
I think we got time five five streams
yeah and you know we're still like kind
of basically noobs and we won't survive
without the chat helping us out telling
Evan to eat but it's so fun and I'm so
excited right now we're building like a
little garden yeah outside of our house
and like me here a house nicer we've
also dug down and mined a bunch of stuff
and then we all we pillaged a village
it's so fun I've been talking more about
your thing in the weekend oh no I love
it I love it like we want to do so much
and it's so interesting because like the
very first time like I had faith in this
game and I had high hopes for it because
the great thing about Minecraft is it's
like you can play it forever so it can
always be something that we'd go back to
it's like a comfort thing for some
reason for me it's like really like cozy
and warm yeah almost and I think that
was the other thing I was gonna say I
think you were gonna talk about our
first stream oh yeah the very first
stream Kaelin was like very hesitant yes
well I don't typically do well with
games that don't have like solid goals
hmm and I know that there's like a
dragon at the end that you're supposed
to kill and stuff like that and there
are leagues that was like the thing that
I told her to get her playing there is a
dragon at the end it's true but like not
even fully the point yeah that's not
really like the point of it oh you know
yeah and there's still like other games
that are kind of like sandbox type games
like that I don't really get in to like
you you've you've tried it like we've
tried a couple other ones there
or like where you make soup and stuff oh
yeah yeah and we make like soup factory
zone yeah and I wasn't really into that
and the first minecraft stream was one
of the most stressful yeah you had you
didn't like at the end of it you're like
I can do it once more but I'm not sure
if I like it the second one like this I
like learned how to craft so I didn't
have to rely on you to make things for
me and I learned how to not die which is
great for the whole so it's like you get
attached to that world I love the world
that we're in you know that mountain
that we found and decided to call home
we battled those like phantoms the first
night and like somewhere somewhere in
the world Kalin is our green top house
like the very first house that we built
together I think there might be two
green top houses somewhere out there in
the world for us to find in the future
like like archaeologists like remember
this our early houses you know yeah and
then we're just gonna keep on expanding
I'm not sure if I've told you this
Caitlin but the world and minecraft
they're infinite yeah infinite the the
worlds generate as you explore so you
can keep on exploring and exploring and
exploring and it never runs out in a way
there's like more villages there's more
like just like abandon your stashes and
stuff everywhere you go no I don't know
I think we could make like roads and
stuff you can make railroads and stuff
to go between your encampments you can
make different villages I think that we
should probably just like make like what
I want to do and this sounds like a
little bit weird
but I want to shape our mountain a
little bit and try to do a cat like find
a way to like get up the mountainside
and like build up two ears and like
maybe even like put lava as I have like
2 2 2 2 eyes or this pouring out lava
when
be the coolest thing to build in
survival mode because like there's a
free play mode where you just like get
like godlike powers you can fly around
anywhere you can terraform anywhere you
have all blocks available and then you
can just like sculpt sculptures but like
where's the challenge in that I want a
stairway that we need to walk up to that
tunnels through the mountain up to the
top then we can walk through to go to
the top and then we tear format and then
we and then we like make the eyes and
everything it's gonna be awesome
it might not be the most exciting stream
but by the end we will be victorious
well at the same time we you know we can
keep on playing until we find the wings
and then like you can make wings and you
can fly around a little bit that might
make a little bit easier and then if we
fall off the cliff then we won't die no
no so my thing is like thought about my
craft for a while there my thing a week
is a video so um a lot of you guys know
that we are a big simply illogical fans
it's a YouTube channel run by Christine
Ridge
yeah Christine with no H and um one of
her recent videos is she she has two
cats
xyler and men she and she tries all
these different methods of taking them
out side like with these various
contraptions so there's like the cat
harness there's the little space bubble
cat backpack and then there's a cat
stroller
hmm so if you like and you know she she
like makes sure that they're okay with
it she doesn't push them or anything
I'm she's a very good cat mom but it was
so fun cuz like I really want to get the
supervisor a little harness so we can
take her on walks
I think it'd be a fun adventure I think
it'd be a really fun adventure I don't
think she would like she might like the
stroller I do not think she would like
the backpack oh no no no no she probably
yeah you do not be into this you might
like the stroller smell like the sturla
cuz she likes being pushed around like
in a shame cause um like Kailyn are we
gonna get a cat stroller
we probably won't only do they don't
want it as like a big thing like
foldable oh it's not gonna be as good as
much you can buy what we're gonna make
it out of this big blocky thing maybe
like a cat wagon do we just buy a wagon
and then put her mom in it yeah just
like put her like like carrying around
it put some blankets in there yeah
blankets and mesh mm-hmm might be a fun
idea
maybe but yeah she really likes being
pushed around like in her box so you
know we usually have like where are we
gonna store it no I don't know in the
Attic Cailin what if we just build
another shadow now everyone said we
needed a bigger set are we gonna prove
them right is good required no more shed
no but she likes being pushed around
when she's sleeping in a box because we
have like a couple Amazon boxes around
the house that she like to sleep in and
one of her favorite things is if you
just scoot her around in it she loves it
and like if you are scooting it and
she's not in it she'll hop in it
so that she can be scooted so she might
like that the stroller so maybe we get a
big cardboard box that's about the size
of a little wagon like a red wheel wagon
or something
we cut holes in it add some mesh to the
sides trap her in the box put her in the
wagon and then carry her around yeah we
may read yeah maybe it's like good
wholesome cat stuff yeah which I love
all right guys well hey thank you so
much for joining us on today's podcast I
know that this was a little bit of a
different one we kind of like we went in
with very little plan and we just wanted
to kind of like do stream of conscious
and like record this moment and share it
with you guys in as raw form as we can
yeah I think that we led to some
interesting places
reading y'all's request in terms of you
know what kind of podcast you want and
it seems like you guys really like story
times so we thought it'd be fun to do
like a full story time hot off the press
hot off the press how does the fresh
that's what they said back in the day
you're fresh hello thank you bye-bye
leave comments ugly ratings movies thank
you
[Music]